oh can't bigger me laws you know how it
is Oh Canada some migrants bus from New
York to the great white North are
wanting to come back because there's too
much snow New York City has been handing
out free tickets to migrants who were
complaining about all the crime and
filth so mayor Eric Adams is now being
slammed as hypocritical after saying
that Texas governor busting migrants was
inhumane but Adams insists no one is
encouraging anyone to go to another
country he's just assisting migrants
with their requests all right Lawrence
he said as recently as four months ago
it is unfortunate inhumane Un-American
unethical to send the migrants or the
illegals from Texas to New York and now
he's shipping them off to Canada but
he's just accommodating him it's easy to
talk like that when they're not on your
Turf when you have to deal with the
problem then you have a different
philosophy Texas are very compassionate
and we've been compassionate for some
years but you're overflowed at all our
hotels took all the food supply in some
of the towns try some of the towns so
again it only goes so far but I got to
say something because I think it's
important the American people are very
compassionate and they like to be
welcoming the people that are coming
across the border better be very careful
of how they're acting lately I mean the
entitlement of saying what you're
entitled to when you broke our laws to
get into the country you're just going
to turn people away and you only got a
little bit left yeah but Greg when you
got Joe Biden as a president who cares
do you know they don't like the food
they can Trash a hotel in New York City
they want to go to Canada we're buying
them tickets they want to come back we
let them in what's wrong with it this is
the one of the funniest stories ever I
mean if you a they were fleeing America
because of the crime and the filth so
now we are the country they were seeking
Asylum for from then when they were here
they didn't want other people to come in
they were not good enough so they meet
really went from Asylum Seekers to Ann
Coulter like in literally one day uh and
and then they're complaining about the
weather and so the obvious truth is they
were never Asylum Seekers to begin with
they were seeking what everybody wants
which is happiness but they were seeking
incentives but it's not Asylum you can't
call it Asylum when they leave their
family behind and then they send money I
mean there's no I mean it sounds like
they were fleeing like a Club Med in
Mazatlan it's like if they're
complaining about the weather stop it
this ain't a this we were being lied to
the whole time that's the funny part
okay Jessica what does it say about our
liberal Sanctuary cities and even the
migrants don't want to be here
it's ridiculous it was like a three and
a half star hotel that's nice yeah it's
completely fine laundry service liberals
go to nice hotels
um
he's saying quick I I got mad about this
I I'm on the record as already saying
don't make people like me who advocate
for people like you look like idiots
look Canada is very nice America is very
nice all of this is nicer than Honduras
Guatemala whatever you said that you
were fleeing take the job work hard
contribute to the system
I am done look I think people should
acknowledge the the unemployment lines
here in New York City drive up and down
Midtown Manhattan they're wrapped around
the block some of them are soup kitchens
I'm not making any statement other than
there is a reality here that the
residents living here are struggling
through every single day resources are
tight and adding all this to the mix
with no Solutions this is just getting
worse and worse right out right down the
street give people free stuff
to be citizens they respect the process
because they didn't go through it I
agree hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else